ski go
fuel okay ski goo so in this form Mike's
doing a ski he's thrusting in towards me
now generally I'd like to blend to the
outside of this but in this form I got
stuck to the inside so I'm going to
blend the inside it's not ideal but it's
still doable so as Mike comes in I'm
going to step back blending to the
inside now here I'm shielding my body
from Mike's attack I'm not trying to
grab his hand out of the air he had a
knife in his hand and I came in like
this and he simply turned it towards me
he would cut me if I put a little fence
up like this though now Mike would have
to recover his knife right which I
followed in on that case but I got lucky
here so right after it came in I grab
and I'm going to drive him forward much
much like an eal as that happens I grab
here and apply the Goku driving him down
here so I'm using the force of the goio
to fold his wrist as I drive his
shoulder down to the mat from here I
apply goio once he gives me the tap then
he's going to simulate someone pulling
their arm in for me and as he pulls his
arm in I put it against the mat and I
get my second go one more time at
speed ski
goldi